today I'm going to show you exactly how
you can get people to open up to you
part one first you have to learn to
reduce your filter if you think about it
the reason why we are scared to say
certain things or to act in certain ways
is because we are afraid of how others
will react instead of talking about
things that we really want to talk about
we put on a filter and we spend most of
our time conversing in small talk but
secretly deep down inside we're all
looking for someone who we can share our
strange thoughts and ideas with now if
you come along and you show them from
the start that you don't really care
about being a perfect snowflake that you
don't really filter yourself and that
you are willing to talk about things
that are deemed as socially unacceptable
or strange then people will want to open
up to you now it's very important to
note that there is a fine line between
being seen as someone who has a reduced
filter and being seen as someone who is
just plain old crazy and it all depends
on your perceived value if your value is
too low people will just think that
you're crazy follow us for more helpful
tips